the Joe Rogan experience yeah it's made
me a better driver one time you know in
a fight in a martial arts fight I
knocked this guy out he never got up and
I I started thinking then that could be
me
they took him away to the hospital and I
went back to talk to my instructor and
he wasn't there it was in Anaheim
California and I was living in Boston we
flew back to Boston after the tournament
and he said to me I heard you had a
really good knockout you know this thick
Korean accent and I said yeah I go it
was um it was really scary because he
never got up
yeah I go it was I thought he was dead
and he goes sometimes they die chief
they just walked away like he used to
train troops in Vietnam like he was like
an intense guy and I was like sometimes
they die holy [ __ ] I'm them them is me
well I could die I was 19 and I remember
I never thought about the same way again
and I've never thought about hitting
someone the same way again because it
was one of those but like sometimes he
hit someone and it's like a perfect shot
like the hit him they were running it he
was running toward he was coming at me
and I kicked him with something called a
wheel kick we it has a crazy amount of
power you spin around and you hit
someone with the heel of your foot it's
a heart my heel hurt for days
I was limping walking from hitting his
head yeah it was rough have you ever
been hitting away that you're like that
could be no no no I've been dropped and
I've been rocked and I've definitely
been hit but I've never been knocked
unconscious and not like that that was a
bad one he was like face face-planted he
was snoring I've seen a lot of people
get knocked out did you have you checked
on him recently I have no idea who he is
wow I've known I've no idea what
happened to him
you want CTE probably murdered his whole
family as well a hundred percent he got
brain damage
what's 100 percent what's 100 percent
whoa Jose no way he didn't oh my god no
way didn't what could that happen to you
look of course it could have happened
absolutely could it happen to you now
and the way that you're fighting I don't
do it anymore
I do Jiu Jitsu right but it's not
striking see this is not it's not like
kick and this was not like sparring this
was a fight this was in the US Nationals
Wow is the Massachusetts state champion
and he was a champion I think he was
from Illinois mmm and so he was the
Illinois state champion did you get like
so much [ __ ] back then from being like
winning fights were there like groupies
no there's no group no no I got the
opposite of [ __ ]
I was always training I was now yeah
yeah I wouldn't even have sex with my
girlfriend in the the dojo
I wouldn't like she I was teaching there
so I once she was horny and she was
trying to hook up with me like I was I
had to go up there to do something clean
or something I forgot but I had to do
but she was trying to I'm like I can't
talk but this is not we can't do this
here this is not this is never gonna
happen here which is like I would [ __ ]
her in an alleyway [ __ ] her on a bus
if no one was looking they nodded the
dough she's not there
no it's actually in Korean it's called
dojang they would call dojang but um no
I didn't get any [ __ ] I mean other than
my girlfriend and then when you start
comedy like so much yeah dude it was
crazy I was the crazy thing that's like
like all sudden girls actually like me
like instead of me liking them and then
rejecting me because I was basically a
loser you know even though I was like a
successful martial artist I had no money
and no future prospects and there was no
promise to me you know it's like where's
this guy going
[Applause]